hey guys it's Greg I'm John people have
noticed that they think I have had a
mental breakdown and maybe I have lost
my mind or me may know exactly what I'm
doing
what would clash with movie are you
preparing a scene for your acting class
so this is your funny guy so we're gonna
check out the trailer do our uh James
Wands the conjuring dos starring Patrick
Wilson and Vera farm for Micah Farmiga
or as I used to call her Vera Virgina
yeah I remember those yeah she's
beautiful she's she's gorgeous woman
Patrick Wilson fantastic actor loves to
get naked ha I think he's really
talented I thought I did a great job in
Batman V Superman comment in the comment
boxes if you know what I'm referring
yeah yeah there's an Easter Egg for ya
he's my um yeah no this is not your
house now what's your name my name they
feel welcome and I'm 72 years old what
do you make of that for us what sounds
confused to see that the voice on this
tape is coming from an 11 year old girl
you're calling it England's a medieval
there is a family that desperately needs
our help
after everything we've seen there isn't
much that rattles either of us anymore
but this one this one still wants me
does it feel like the voice is coming
from inside you
well no like it's coming from behind
making me my god being years
Jannetty all right stop calling Lee
Carter she's such a good girl
so what without an oppressing Spirit
will try to force you to commit the
ultimate sin
what's that murder suicide or both
you believe Austin sensing a presence
sensing anything all I can sense is
their own fear maybe you're bleeding
what is happening I had a premonition of
your death
yeah
the family's just a pawn
something inhuman wants to kill you
if we keep doing this
you're going to die
I'll a some fun I was like oh yeah
you're like right in the mirror there's
one just [ __ ] with you forever I was
like I know good like right when they
panned over I was like okay here we go
you're about to you're about to reinvent
the jump-scare again yeah that was great
that's a great jump scared that one jump
scare has sold me on this whole phone
hey man I mean this this looks crazy I
mean this looks like it's every James
Wan ghost movie seems to like borrow
like you know pay homage to a specific
movie and this one feels like it wants
to be the Exorcist yeah I mean I get a
big vibe at a young girl possessed has
the voice of a 72 year old man and
except it doesn't seem like she's only
possessed it seems like he goes back and
forth
oh yeah not enough to say that it's like
that it's like a direct thing but it
seems like he he probably watched that
as inspiration he wanted me totally
feels like The Exorcist cuz it has that
sort of like austerity in that older
time I know there's something about the
way that it's frame that feels like more
akin to the Exorcist than poltergeist
you know which insidious clearly loves
poltergeist yeah we talked a lot about
this in the first trailer that we saw
for this so if you want to hear like
more opinions you go to that video but I
just want to say like you know James Wan
is entering like the big leagues now you
know I need a Furious 7 I was doing
Aquaman before and he has this coming
out which is cool because it's a much
lower budget and everything then what
he's now getting access to yeah I hope
he doesn't get lost in you know major
studio movies I really hope that doesn't
happen and I want to say I would like
this to primarily be his franchise
because I think it's cool that he knows
how to take inspiration from other films
and sort of make TWiT make the genre a
little different you know when he's
bringing back stuff that we're kind of
sorely lacking now because again this
does feel to me it kind of evocative of
like Rosemary's Baby and and and The
Exorcist is like that and they don't
make a lot of those anymore
it's cool to see that and then like in
the future if he continued these
conjuring movies maybe we can see one
that's like giallo or you know something
else yeah so the way he pays homage is
really cool because he's bringing older
stuff back like in the prop
says like he's used the franchise format
in really clever way to make up some
cool move but this is a franchise um I'm
on board for you know it's like I want
to see the Warrens next adventure the
next case yeah you know like and I like
to see that John worse which like some
different element of horror plus
whatever you know yeah it's like it
keeps it fresh every time and it gives
them new toys to play with
so yeah the best of both yeah I hope he
doesn't get like mired up in the in the
gigantic studio system like I hope he
can get get kind of like an Edgar Wright
thing where it's just like yeah they
trust him he doesn't think cuz like he's
he's done it enough times now we're like
even the films of his people don't like
are still pretty well crafted so I think
he knows how to do it you know I think I
said this in the last trailer but I like
from the marketing what they're showing
us is it's much more personal for them
this time you know like it's really
getting involved with like Lorraine hurt
her character and you know like seeing
how they're pretty much after her too
and she's had these premonitions and
stuff and because you know I'm like the
first conjuring it was like Ron
Livingston's family yeah and you know
because it picks up a little bit after
office space yeah yeah they fired him
for that pretty yeah so it's wrong
Livingston's family who's mainly being
haunted and the Warrens are like the
heroes you know you feel safe when
they're around and this time you know I
don't think I'm gonna feel that much
safety yeah which is a good way to play
because they are the first movie it's
like oh [ __ ] this thing that we don't
know how to deal with these people know
about yeah these guys are gonna be fine
and now that we know it's like oh ship
is my one be too big this might be too
big for them to handle you know is that
what she said and that's nah that's
that's what I'm curious about with this
movie like with John Oh what I was a
good that's what she said moment it was
it was are you okay yeah I mean Dee I
didn't feel it I felt it I felt it in my
in my in my I felt it I thought it was a
great great that's where she's I think
it was a good one yeah I walked right
into it yeah
she didn't say she didn't know well who
is she I mean do we we need to ask more
questions they wanted to probe it the
truth
oh I don't know if she reads it then it
is a bit of a long trailer I will say
that like I don't think it as long as
that's not the list of the movie I don't
think it gave away too much but there
was a point where I was like I have seen
enough I am there I will be there I
assure you okay yes I feel that way I
mean like I I don't I cannot tell you
how I think this film will play out yeah
sure you know I can't tell you like how
like oh here's how it's probably gonna
go in the beats and they know like yeah
no they just show you a lot of like
dread Eid yeah moments like it's it's
it's totally on point I just was like
I'm happy about all this but you know is
a lot like I want at least feel like the
scenes a friend don't worry there's
still two more hours of footage
sorry I swallowed air wrong um this
whole switch has just got me riled up
well [ __ ] yeah guys thanks for sending
that our way that's that is going to be
a killer film I'm sure they're excited
and if you're new to the channel you can
subscribe today become part of the
reject community how cool would that be
yeah a community where where i rana CLE
we are no longer rejected cuz we're
community okay but we still keep the
name ironically we're rejected from all
the other yeah I made that joke like a
like a billion times oh sorry I wasn't
here that's not new territory
okay well I'm big just wait wait cuz
like agree that we were gonna re answer
this with more witty comic the 10-minute
version of this joke is much better
tells me laughter we're not worried
yeah we'll record it just it'll be a
podcast yeah John's playlists are in the
description box you should go check them
out one is all the videos he's featured
and the other one is dank a Stubbs a
podcast that would cost patiently
uploads for you can we just record a new
good for you guys I can't wait for you
guys to edit that podcast and you can
follow us on our social networks the
Facebook's the instagrams the Twitter's
and I wanted to say a thank you again to
all the subscribers I know you
I have been very supportive and I love
the the nice subscribers yes it's no you
know cuz the Internet has that like aw
everyone's gonna eat you alive but you
know having some nice people around is
very reassuring I want to do a movie
about a guy who's a successful youtuber
and then every mean comment he gets he
has a tracking system to find out who is
saying this and he goes on a murderous
rampage and kills everyone who will play
the reactor um I said youtuber not a
really sorry youtuber okay well the
reactors gonna be played by me oh you
yeah I was thinking like Jake Gyllenhaal
yeah I'm gonna be playing myself oh this
is a documentary I'm working on okay you
is Greg yeah ba-bling and I'm Ryan right
oh [ __ ] oh face of mistake